we're confronting historic challenges
and so what we've learned over the last
uh many months as we've watched this uh
unprovoked and illegal invasion of
Russia into Ukraine what we've learned
is that you know countries have to
invest in their in their defense and I
think I say we I think we know that
already and and most everybody knows
that already but it became real as we
saw this unfold and so countries are
leaning forward in and and more than
willing to invest in uh in their defense
and as we continue to discuss this I
think there is Broad agreement that the
two percent investment two percent of
GDP investment should be a floor and not
a ceiling and and and there are many
countries that are anxious to exceed the
two percent